yeah getting back getting back to why i
know like americans don't drink tea
right
yeah one kettle's a [ __ ] two like okay
so
i remember i was staying with sydney and
uh she had like a little bit of or
someone had a sore throat right so we
just needed some warm water
right and so how would you make warm
water right
boiling boiling water and then put you
know put the hot water in and just
fill it for that with cold water so
sydney
takes the mug and oh
puts it in the microwave and puts on a
counter
and i'm just like what are you doing
sydney i feel like i'm getting a brain
aneurysm just watching this right now
that's horrible and i was just like
there's nobody there's no there's no way
this is normal right there's no way this
is [ __ ] normal
and so she says no it's it's a normal
thing here and i'm just like
bet and i tweet i'm just like americans
is this a normal thing to do
and the amount of like what's wrong well
how how do you heat up your water
like i'm just like how is this
how have we gone through like thousands
of years of civilization
to heat up water in a microwave i'm
going to do my my
obligatory insult america mark that off
the bingo
americans literally think the microwave
is like
a tool from god yeah you can do
everything
the kitchen nightmares just taught me
that thank you okay it's totally reality
obviously
you know i recently i i abandoned
my kettle in japan i got rid of it
really it was you know
british cattle's a lot intense like
also you know i i i when i when we boil
kettles in the uk it's down in what like
one minute
yeah two minutes max yeah that's a [ __ ]
cattle if it's any longer than that yeah
and you won't get even the shittiest of
cattles don't do
like the worst kettles you find are in
hotels that like you put the water in
you come back 40 minutes later shit's
still boiling making like
the world's loudest sound somehow it's
like
it's like how is this the shittest cat
this is a change surely you could have
got a deal from the manufacturer to get
a
not [ __ ] capital half the water's
evaporated by the time yeah yeah it's
gone by the time you [ __ ] but you get
[ __ ] 200 milliliters of water it's
like not even fills up the cup
it's absolutely abysmal it's like pretty
but like wasted half the [ __ ] hotels
electricity as well
it's [ __ ] dreadful but in japan as
well as they have the same thing and
america is the same the kettles take so
goddamn long to boil
and they're so [ __ ] i got so tired of it
because i'm streaming between games
yeah i don't want to be waiting for like
five minutes yeah exactly i'm streaming
i can't i can't sit there and wait
so i i i found like japan has these
things that i've again i've never seen
these before but
they're just like uh they have them in
conbini's where it's like this a boiling
water jug
oh i know i know you can fill the ramen
yeah oh yes
the ones where you like can pour it
right yeah yeah
it's like a two liter jug or whatever
yeah you fill it up with water
and then it boils it or it doesn't boil
it puts it like you can choose the
temperature yeah yeah
and it's just i mean it's just always
hot it's always hard yeah yeah and i
think it uses
less less electricity than constantly
reboiling the cattle yeah
yeah um and uh yeah i felt so big brain
because now
you know when i i just have hot water
ready right literally i can just go to
the thing put the bag in
boom hot water i'm like sure because
because that's because that's what every
asian uses for like cup ramen yeah
that's that's the cup ramen machine and
tea machine yeah and then i'm like [ __ ]
maybe
maybe kettles are obsolete this is the
wind away
goodbye kettles i was kind of like [ __ ]
i've kettle has been like the first
appliance i buy i
i never thought about it like that
because i've seen that all the time in
asia because that's that's
just readily available whenever i'd come
to thailand holy [ __ ] yeah that's true
that's true that is more efficient it's
so much more efficient and you literally
have it ready but anything's better than
a [ __ ] microwave okay
please don't do that stick [ __ ] stop it
get help
so so in a it's called sixth form in the
uk i've got what's called america
we we there was a guy and we had like uh
we had a microwave and a kettle in our
you know like dorm room or like chill
room it's for like the yeah we got two
years left
and uh this guy was like you want a cup
of tea i was like yeah i'll have a cup
of tea
you won't believe this man he puts water
in the cup puts the tea bag in and puts
in the microwave
oh my i'm about to [ __ ] i'm about to
[ __ ] leave right now
like he pours the water cold into the
the cup with the tea bag
cold lets it like stew and puts it in
the microwave and heats it up
and i've never seen anyone else do this
and i'm like who taught you this
like someone had to teach you this
because no one else would ever do this
and i'm like
i bet his [ __ ] parents are freaks
what else should they do
do they like [ __ ] eat their toenails
like what else is going on in this
household like you can't trust them when
they do that [ __ ]
it's like it's like the family was like
let's make let's make some tea and it's
cold and then and then one day they
discovered
people drink tea and then and then i
really then i realized
i'm like [ __ ] this is the most british
thing ever because he got shipped for it
for like a year and a half
and i'm like i think he'd be able to be
in america he literally got bullied for
a year and a half for making t
wrong isn't that the most british thing
you've ever heard that's well deserved
honestly like you you know like you know
like that [ __ ] meme where you know if
aliens ever
invaded like humanity and they had to
blend in with the crowd
that's the kind of [ __ ] we were looking
forward to be like oh you're you're on
[ __ ] impossible
human
alien movement cup of tea
honestly there's nothing more british
than being like being like
very possessive over our team being very
protective over our team did i tell you
about the
shittest cup of tea my brother ever made
me okay you made two of them you made
two of them
you know and this is the this is the
problem uh when you kind of do it half
right and then [ __ ] up one step is that
it looks good
it smells good it looks as it should so
the first time he did it for me i asked
him to make me a cup of tea and he
reluctantly said yes
i can't remember how i convinced him
because he would never do anything right
he was you should brother he never does
anything nice for me
that's been in a good mood yeah i don't
know something right so he makes me a
cup of tea and i'm drinking it
and i'm like i get to the end like
he [ __ ] ripped the bag open
[Laughter]
because he never made a cup of tea
before so he assumed
the bag was like oh this is what's all
this [ __ ] in this bag
because i think i think what happened
was that he'd had instant coffee before
right and he thought he thought it
looked like instant coffee
so he thought that he ripped the bag
open pour in the perfectly portioned
instant tea and then he stirred it
and then i get to the end of this and i
[ __ ] choke it on these shitty
shitty tea leaves and then i scalded him
i never let him forget it and then again
you know like a year or two later he
makes me another cup of tea right
and i can't [ __ ] up a cup of tea more
than once yeah right this is this is it
so this was actually at the paintballing
place i remember this because i was like
literally [ __ ] freezing right we're
covered in mud i'm like oh she want a
good cup of tea i was like oh and you're
on the because it was it was uh my
little brother
some of his friends some of my friends
and i was like oh you you're on the
tee duty so he goes for me he goes to
make a cup of tea for like me
and like six other people yeah i swear
it must have been like you know
like it was like some kind of cult
poisoning-esque thing
because we'd all drink our tea and when
we get to the bottom he [ __ ] left the
bag in
he put the milk in right so you can't
right
i'm like you're british you're 15 years
of age you have no excuse this should
never have happened
there's literally there should have been
things to stop this isn't this what
school is for
of all the different ways he could have
[ __ ] up tea he did all of them
pretty sure he could be exiled from
england doing that right
i'm pretty sure a lot of british people
would like kick you out of their house
like that probably breaks it happened
right
they're like [ __ ] europeans can't
make a call make a good cup of tea